[Applaudissements]
c'est la femme du siècle et je
parle de son âme maintenant hé ça
sonne bonjour je pensais
[Musique]
dieu je suis fort content de te voir tu peux
parler tu vas me dire Oh mieux
oui tu l'es
moi  Je suis désolé que nous n'ayons pas appelé la
note que nous nous cachons pour moi rencontrer Mary Ann et
tirer oh j'aurais dû savoir que tu amènerais
un protégé
je voulais dire que le beurre te regarde
cool
est-ce qu'ils comprennent oui est que lire pour
être perdu  fais ça il y a combien d'années
tu es plutôt domestiqué pour une rock
star ai-je fait quelque chose pour te contrarier
[Musique]
cela ne veut pas dire que tu ne veux pas que nous soyons
meilleurs amis que frères
[Musique]
nous nous battons juste arrête de parler
le  le monde n'est pas prêt tu es honnête
quel est l'intérêt de la piscine dans ta vie
tu ne mérites plus aucun des deux je
tombe amoureux de chaque jolie chose que tu
ne veux pas faire ça
éclate  du siècle rien de
ce que je t'ai fait